my guest tonight won an emmy award for
his work on will and grace and now he
has
two great don't turn around and look at
it you know this dude i know but i just
want to make sure it's accurate while
we're doing it now he has
two great podcasts oh yeah the very uh
popular smartlist and his new podcast
hypochondriactor please welcome our good
friend
sean hayes sean what you were saying
three what does this mean you have three
podcasts now no i was gonna say
if we're doing a numbers thing it's
three emmys and two podcasts
what did i say did i just say one emmy
you said one for that show so that was
correct
but i just thought let's we could like
play with numbers for a while by the way
the energy is incredible here
the i mean you can surf this energy you
construct this energy this is there is
as many as four people in the audience
wow every night yeah and that was before
kovit wow
um whoa i saw everything did you see my
penis
you have assless chaps on well they said
it was gonna be a ride
no how many emmys do you have three
three then why did we say one emmy
because you said for that show but
that's
stupid i should say start what do you
have the other enemies for i don't
remember
you don't remember you're that big
that's how famous i am
good god
all i can say is this is winning the
crowd over sean yeah
i just saw seven cardboard people walk
out
and six come back in and replace them
because there's a waiting line
this is the truth about sean hayes you
came in
we were sitting here it took my crew not
their fault
but they're a little hungover it took
them about 15 minutes to get set up yeah
and um you were hilarious the whole time
and i'm thinking
we should be shooting this this is the
show
but of course they were uh they were
loaded on whatever they were doing last
night no
i was like i was just saying are we we
yeah i was like are we shoot are we
shooting now we're shooting because i
didn't know if you did like
a thing where you like i mean let's turn
the cameras on but not tell the talent
so we get some really good stuff
this is the good stuff right yeah oh wow
yeah
this is stretch it out for commercial
right
this is let's go right and then this is
the really good stuff
and this is a good joke from conan whoa
look at that
anyway oh he left his lips when you that
was weird well
i'm allowed to do whatever i want here
on conan
uh you know thank you for being here i
know you're being paid i looked into it
you're getting
like 700 to be here that's incredible
yes do you want to split it
yes i do actually i don't get that money
that goes just to the talent
so what did you get paid for it like
today just for today
okay let's see uh i get paid
if i had to break it down day to day
yeah yeah i'm probably making like
400 today wow if you had to just say
what i was making so why don't you just
be a guest every day somewhere
i'm such an idiot if i was the guest i'd
make 70. that's right
i should do that why don't you interview
yourself every episode then it's 700
plus
400 that could be that's thousands of
dollars
um you know
you are such a busy guy
how busy am i well you're so busy that
you're constantly working of course in
television
but you've got these hilarious podcasts
i i went on uh yes you were so kind to
come on smart list
i came on smart was cause it's you it's
mr
uh will arnett and uh jason bateman
yeah um i just do that
he said very little the whole time i
have to say that guy's coasting on that
podcast
but uh you guys were hilarious oh thanks
yeah no you were very very nice to come
on if you haven't checked it out check
it out the conceit is that one of us
acts as a host
and brings on a guest that the other two
don't know about so it's all through
zoom
so the guest covers up their camera or
they put like a little posted on it and
we introduce them and they reveal
themselves
to the other two a very good thing and
then uh i was
i wasn't quite talking to some people
recently oh i was done with it okay yeah
i i i just decide when the i've been
doing this so long i decide
when the anecdote's over and i just go
okay okay i'd love to come back
anyway
[Laughter]
i was going to say a nice thing which is
that i guess you had stephen colbert on
and he told some crazy story about me
which is insane and not in the realm of
possibility well
anyway i'm just saying he does he feels
differently he feels differently and
um and uh i think the story has me on a
ski lift
yeah what am i doing on the ski lift i
love that he's acting like he's not he
doesn't know
oh i thought you told me about i was no
i had heard about it you pulled your
pants down in front of a group
of children and you shat on them yes yes
stephen colbert tells this story because
what's true is that he and i were skiing
once together and we were on a ski lift
and then
and and suspended in the air and he
tells this insane story about me taking
my pants off on the ski lift
and then uh defecating on children who
were sitting below
okay fantastic so i run into these
people this is a couple of weeks ago i
run into these people and they said the
children
no not the children it was the children
and they're like they're covered
um no i ran into these very nice people
who were chatting they recognized me and
they start chatting with me
oh my god we were listening to the
funniest podcast and steven colbert told
me this story about and they told the
thing that stephen had said and i'm
laughing really hard and going yeah yeah
and then they stopped and they went
is it true and i was like yes
i just decided to say yes it's true
because you can't deny that no of course
what are you talking about i took my
pants off
and pooped on people on a ski lift well
i mean it's you're doing a very well job
of acting like you didn't do it now
listen
i just think the control it would take
the aim yeah
that's the part that's what you even
described the pants you were wearing
with the
secret panel in the back that comes down
for ease that's
true that is true anyway i love these
people
relating this story to me about me on a
public ski lift
pooping on people below and laughing and
then they're like is it true
wait but did you listen to it did you
listen to that episode you have to
listen i didn't listen to the episode
if i listen to every episode of every
podcast where i'm name checked
and talked about with great reference oh
so famous is this i'm a so famous story
i'm sorry it's not possible there's not
enough time in the day because you're so
popular
exactly thank you but my other podcast
yes we're going to get to that podcast
why don't you go dead in the eyes i'm
waiting to talk about the other podcasts
i know we're i'm gonna get
this is all gonna be on the show that's
[ __ ] to do
the hypochondriactor
well the segways are incredible well i'm
sorry you left me no choice
when you go dead in the eyes and say
other podcasts
i have no choice but to move on to the
other podcast
which is you talking about your
crazy history of medical maladies and it
sounds like a fantastic show it really
does
thank you very sweet yeah no it's called
hypochondria my i'm kind of like a
self-diagnosed
hypochondriac or not clinical but you
know i've been obsessed with medical
stories my whole life when i hear about
them or read about them
i think it's going to happen to me if it
hasn't happened to me it's going to
happen to me kind of even when the covet
happened i'm walking down the street i'm
like oh my god did that guy just kidding
you know i mean we all kind of feel like
i feel that way all the time and so
uh and this happened i mean you were
having stuff happen to you as a kid
yeah you come by this honestly because
you've had some real medical issues
right right
that got you really interested like for
example when you were a kid this sounds
crazy to me you know where i'm going
uh i don't remember you would
pass out yes you would just pass out as
a child yes
and so much so that you don't even
remember it and i have to remind you yes
i know thank you if you could follow me
home too that would be great
no i i have a condition called vasovagal
do you know what that is i don't okay so
vasovagal is when you faint easily like
from
anything right so when i was a kid i
broke my arm in third grade
and i was holding my arm the whole day
and i didn't know and finally teacher's
like you're all right i'm like
i don't think so so it's broke my mom
meets me at the at the hospital they
wrap it you know in a cast which is like
paper mache and i passed out because i
don't know why because i was i don't
know it's just all overwhelming
so my mom had smelling salts in her
purse and she's like here smell these
like first of all smells like salts in
their that's insane i don't know it's
i have no idea why she had that in her
purse it it keeps me wondering
late at night but um so uh that happened
and then i passed out like getting
contact lenses twice i like
i think the poking in the eye the
repetitive poking and i passed out twice
the same you know the same uh visit to
the doctor and then i passed out getting
a uh at the dentist in the chair like
just the poking right the poking
and then i tried botox like five or six
years ago
some stupid joke about me trying bone
tax go ahead no i'm not gonna do that
okay
so you didn't die but you stopped when
when did you stop
or have you not see that's the funny
thing
so no i tried it like five or six years
ago and
uh just to write the poking and i was
like first of all i'm never doing this
again second i was like
i got do you have a fan or something you
turn on i'm getting hot and i'm gonna
faint
and he's like no i'm like okay are we
done he's like yeah we're done so i had
like 20 seconds to go before i was going
to hit the floor
i'm trying to exit and the lady behind
the the counter she's like you're gonna
pay i was like oh
and i'm like ten nine eight you know my
credit card she's
she swipes it i sign i throw the pen
under and i go outside
and i pass out in the hallway on the
ground
yeah did anyone find you no nobody found
me i made it i made it out
i can't i can't believe i did it but it
was nice and cold yeah but
because that's what you're looking for
when you feel faint right you're looking
for like a cold surface i don't know
i don't think i think i don't not
fainted in my life i will i will
well you've been like you've drank too
much at least some point in your life
where you're like
i feel like right nobody because i'm
irish yeah
is that it just because i'm irish yeah
no uh
never fainted incredible lack of
medical problems on my end
i don't know why i'm talking about
you're literally speaking in fragments
happening stroke now bragging about no
medical problems and then sleep yes
no but then yeah so that so anyway the
point that's dangerous you know it's it
to me just passing out and falling like
that would be very dangerous
yeah no well i mean i knew it was coming
so yeah
yeah uh but but but uh the point is yeah
i've always i've had any
tons of things wrong with me and uh let
me just get this in really quick i
partner on the high
on hypo contractor the podcast with dr
priyanka wally who is an
indian uh woman beautiful gorgeous
amazing super smart intelligent
uh stand-up comedian uh board-certified
practicing physician
like so she does the show with you yeah
she's gonna show me and which i think
would help just because you're laying
out
these different medical issues talking
about these medical things at least you
have
if it's just a comedian it's a waste of
time it's
entertaining but you have someone there
who can say hey wait a minute
let me tell you the history of where
that comes from right i felt like you
were just describing me that i'm a waste
of time
no what i meant was i'm kidding the
doctor who went to medical school
was worth something right and the
comedian's worthless right
do you understand am i making myself
clear
you and i don't matter but people who've
been to medical school right
mean something in the world so
wait a minute but what about like so
so i always say i i truly i like
like if you name a part of my body
inside or out i have a
true story about it i feel like i've had
everything wrong with me
okay let's try this yeah i'm just a
randomly like pancreas did anything ever
go wrong with your pancreas perfectly
fine
and see no nothing within my pancreas
other than i have triglycerides and that
affects the sugar levels which is the
pancreas
so i'm saying kind of watch that you
ever had an intestinal problem
yes my small intestine so about like
three years ago
i had i don't know four four or five
years ago i had about um
i was in the middle of the night three
in the morning and i was like oh my
stomach hurts like
and it was excruciating pain i was like
do i have did my appendix like explode
like what's happening i'm pushing around
i was like oh god it's so much fun
and i felt bad i didn't want to wake up
scotty my husband
what yeah and uh how could that be
a man you're not aware of this but i'm
like 50 years behind the times
[Laughter]
i don't understand why is a man in bed
with you
this doesn't make sense to me
sorry welcome to the conan show it's
1951.
i love that i just couldn't get past
that so wait why don't
you just wake up scotty and tell him
because i felt bad so i drove
myself to the hospital at three in the
morning and i'm going there and i walk
in the air i'm like oh my gosh sometimes
so they they checked me out on emergency
surgery because my small intestine burst
open
so they went in there with uh
scissors and they
are you sure you went to a hospital are
you sure
i went to an elementary school and they
had like elmer's clue i went to an arts
and crafts
class in an elementary school right
right so they went in there snip they
tied it together and here i am but it
was crazy
i didn't know that that's yeah it was
nuts it was like four or five years ago
and
and by the way the doctor like the nurse
was like just checking me on the
surgeon who who performed the surgery
was behind the nurse who was facing me
so he couldn't see
and the guy's like just be careful you
don't drink for a while and the
surgeon's like
and he's like and watch like nuts and
like anything with seeds he goes
who do you believe i believe the surgeon
because he does this thing every day
yeah who do you believe in that
situation anyway yeah so
there you go i remember i wouldn't wait
i want to know did scotty ever find out
that this happened
were you like home before this is this
is the reveal
you should say scotty watch conan
tonight
no he he was furious he was furious yeah
he's sure what are you talking about why
didn't you wake this is reading i don't
want that story out there that you
didn't wake up
i was just like sleeping i was like it's
three in the morning i just got there
years and years ago when i was just
getting started in comedy and i got
shingles in my
eyeball which um the name of your
biography
thank you shingles in my eyeball and it
was so everyone has said that's like the
most painful thing
wow and um i was i had no one to take me
to the hospital so
and i lived in central hollywood so i
just got out
in the in and started walking in the
night like this
to cedar sinai by myself and i couldn't
really see
so i was walking around like this to try
and get to the hospital by my
and then i got there they're like who
brought you here and i said i walked
here
[Laughter]
wait a minute wait with shingles in the
eyes why is this why is the
virus just wants to be so specific i
don't know it was in one eye
and you know what happens it attacks the
optic nerve and so
the up the nerves of the face are
exactly symmetrical so i was like two
face
exactly one half of my face swelled up
and
was red and pustulating and the other
half was fine
and i looked like two-faced from batman
and it's it looks like a carpet like
that
what is it always just one side of the
eye yeah shingles is always holding
on one side of the body let me tell you
guys let me tell you guys something
this is why i started the podcast
because i'm endlessly fascinated with
stories like that
and so that could have been on but you
know this is the thing i would love to
if i got invited
um i'd come on let's see how this goes
this is already gone um i'd love to come
on the podcast because this is why this
podcast sounds good to me
i think all of us are sort of obsessed
with
what's wrong with us or what we think is
wrong with us when we get in our heads
about it and being able to laugh about
it and have an actual doctor there say
here's what's really good right yeah
it's perfect it's exactly why i had it
and that's why i started and so
uh because i think any kind of story
like that reconnects us
and any kind of story like that connects
us
you're not a real you know what you're
not a real person and i'm realizing as i
talk to you i'm not a real person
it's two okay so wait
what i love about the podcast is like
stories like that it connects us
and makes us like if you're watching at
home or listening or whatever to one of
the stories
it kind of makes you feel like you're
less alone if you're going through the
same thing and
you know that's why i i also love it um
and this come out just come out once a
week
this is already out now it comes out
every wednesday let me get the word out
on this podcast yeah
sean's podcast hypochondriactor
get it actor get it
no it's available now
wherever you get your podcast and uh i'm
going to check it out and
look if you ever want to hear me babble
on and on about my
uh infected eye more
[Laughter]
there's so much more to that story i
would love it
you're gonna love it i would love that
and um and by the way
i'm just gonna repeat anyone who hasn't
it's not if it's not clear here
sean haye is one of the funniest people
in real life as well
you really are like that like and we got
together
it was you and scotty and my wife liz
and i and we had dinner and afterwards
you and i
were walking back to our cars and we
started doing routines together in the
parking lot
25 minutes no one was around for 25
minutes and my wife was looking at
scotty and scott he was looking
at my livestream and they were just like
it's this we're in hell with these
people
we're in absolutely i know i know thank
you so much for coming here in person
thank you for having me you really are a
delight i love you very very much
what do you mean that yes wow
[Laughter]
sean hayes everybody